and let's then move to the browns as we
look at the afc north draft needs the
browns can't leave draft weekend without
addressing what and before we answer
that you mentioned 26th overall pick
they also have an extra pick in the
third and an extra pick in the fourth
chris
yeah i i think the one that would jump
out to me more than anything we've hit
the two
you know the two positions i think that
they need the most
pass rusher and to me the next one is
middle linebacker
you know again this is this i hate to
say this and keep repeating this but
it's a seattle scheme there's a formula
that's expected
within this type of with this defense
you need
a legit like fly around linebacker
they need their bobby wagner their fred
warner their miles jack their dion jones
you know uh they're they're
the guy in dallas from notre dame the
middle linebacker i'm blanking on his
name
but these are joan smith yeah right
jalen smith they're darius leonard
from the indianapolis colts it's all the
same defensive scheme
it's all they're all doing it and that
that to me is where
that's what the browns need is that guy
they need a speed
linebacker and there should be one there
you know at the end of the first
first round it'd be interesting to see
who's available but
i think that's the position i'll
probably say they need more than
anything coming away from the draft in
those
first few rounds to answer the question
yeah strictly and literally the browns
can't leave draft weekend without
addressing blank
running back because of nick chubb
they've yet to sign him to a new
contract
they've got kareem hunt under contract
if
they get lucky and throw a dart and get
a guy who can come in
and be nick chubb post nick chubb you
don't have to pay nick chubb
13 14 15 million a year to keep him
around
for 2022 if you choose to go that route
it's a
tough move for a team to make and we see
most of these teams who cultivate
great running backs find a way to extend
the relationship and pay the guy
a lot of money the browns very heavy on
the analytics
of any team out there that would be
willing to say to a star running back
see you later and sorry fans if you
bought the guys jersey you should have
known not to buy running back jerseys
for cleveland browns players if we're
going to go heavy on the analytics
because we're going to find a guy dollar
for dollar far more effective than nick
chubb
one way to do that chris use one of
those third round or fourth round picks
on the best available running back
that's where you can find some great
running backs who can develop into among
the best in the nfl
no no doubt that would be nice that
certainly would be
i mean yes to not have to worry about
you know signing that big contract or
have that next
that running back have to do that i get
you um
either way they got chubb what that was
chubb's third year right
last year so this is his contract this
is the contract year this is the year
either way
uh yeah yeah i mean you make a solid
point there's no doubt about it he's
special
he really is he's one of the five best
running backs in football
and i think really realistically it's
the best duo in football right at the
running back position is there a better
deal
you're one in minnesota is pretty damn
good but this is this is right there
at the top i think but they bought
kareem hunt
so low yeah as a result of the things
that happened when he was on the chiefs
that they have him locked up to a very
very favorable deal
i'm just telling you i don't think the
browns
are going to flinch the way that we've
seen
vikings titans panthers saints flinch
just to keep around a guy who's regarded
as a great running back because that
next great running back is always coming
and the reality is
what is the shelf life what's what's the
real shelf life for a running back
what is it right derrick henry with 2
000 rushing yards this year
now entering year number six how many
more years can derrick henry do it how
long
does any running back consistently play
at a high level like that adrian
peterson is the only one we've seen in
the last 20 years to do it
no i mean you know franklin and frank
gore
yeah but like even that though i mean
you know adrian peterson is really good
there's there's no i mean he's a
superstar
frank gore superstar yes but i mean like
you're talking about
that's two guys in 20 years you know
derek henry
he's kind of a freak show himself too
you know he's different
so he might be able to last a little bit
longer but we're seeing with other guys
that
that's not the case it's definitely not
and i don't know they're in cleveland
you know as far as like a team that
seems to be heavy on the analytics and
things like that
i think you know mike you make a valid
point there's no doubt about that
listen drafting running backs this day
and age now and even like i have to do
my
running back rankings on my podcast
today we're gonna break this down one of
the thoughts i went into
or you have to erase out of your brain
is like screw long term
that thought doesn't exist like don't
evaluate running backs coming out in the
draft to be like
well i think this guy could last six or
seven years
no no i'm looking at a running back
going
is it how awesome is he gonna be for
three or four years and then i'm
thinking i gotta get a new one that's
all there is to it
i can't you can't you can't expect
anything else out of that position
without violent it is so
uh it's a good point by you it's a good
conversation all together
some great running backs who had solid
seasons and then
not demarco murray jamal charles le'veon
bell
ariane foster um you know there are
plenty of guys out there that burn
bright and then that's
it and it's hard to maintain a ton of
spend a period of time and so the
question becomes what do the browns do
and i just think that
before you you above all else even if
you're thinking about keeping nick chubb
you need to have another guy ready to go
as your leverage when you're trying to
get nick chubb
to take a deal that doesn't set a new
bar that doesn't
tie your hands from a salary cap
standpoint at a position where you know
you can find somebody younger and
cheaper and if it turns out the guy's a
home run hitter
who is going to be one of the best
running backs in the nfl then maybe you
can say
to nick chubb thanks for four years
we're
going in a different direction all right
we'll go in a different direction to the
pittsburgh steelers they have the 24th
overall pick
they have plenty of needs especially on
the offensive side of the ball chris
what can they not leave draft weekend
without well that's office alignment
this
is the easy one for pittsburgh i mean it
really is
you know of course we know their defense
is in a pretty good spot wide receivers
in a good spot
you know they're another team that you
know yeah yeah running back we can
certainly they need that there's no
doubt
but i think offensive line is more than
you know is the one thing that just you
just go
wow they need to get younger they need
upgrade
i think it's the reason you saw mike
tomlin and notre dame a few weeks ago
for that pro day
because he's sitting there looking at
liam eichenberg and going wait i need an
nfl ready right and now
can play type nfl offense alignment
notre dame's got two of those this year
so i don't know if it's going to be
somebody in the first round
i think there could be some guys there
certainly at all
at all positions you you could have you
know top notch center guard and tackle
there available
you know at pick number 24 for the
pittsburgh steelers but i think that's
really the big thing and yeah you can't
take it off as a lineman that you feel
like as a project or anything like that
you know as we've talked about here the
whole off season they're they're in it
right now
to win it with big ben so they need an
offensive lineman that they can plug and
play in this nfl ready not a project
that they think will be really great in
two or three years from now
yeah marquis pouncey gone david de
castro's future who knows alejandro
villanueva
still unsigned i guess he potentially
could come back
and rejoin that steelers offensive line
but they need lymon i've said all along
they need a frank o'hara's style of an
impact
running back a guy who comes in as a
rookie and really plays at a high level
and is
durable that's been the issue with james
connor also remains unsigned after
roughly a full month of free agency
where do you think they'd look for a
running back is this a high round
pick le'veon bell was a second rounder
uh
james connor was a third rounder or is
this a
maybe we get lucky with a guy late in
the draft who we can quickly develop but
they
they they don't you know they usually
when they go late round running back
they usually make that guy
wait a few years and work his way up but
look where they are from a rushing
standpoint chris last year 32nd in the
nfl
you could argue they need to use a
couple of picks on running backs this
year and hope that one of those guys
hits
but they've gotten nothing you know out
of the position in the last few years
that's for sure
end of the second round i think there
could be some good ones on the board
certainly that could help their football
team there's no doubt
yeah you know but i don't think you're
gonna see i would be shocked if you see
a running back go
in the first round really so i would
think at some point
after or right around pick 40 you start
to see
the top running backs in the draft go
and and that could certainly
make them in the running for one of
those three four five best running backs
in the draft definitely but
i mean mike i'm with you they they need
something there we've talked about the
steelers
the attitude playing the right way for
the rest of your football team you're a
defensive football team
so of course running the ball and
controlling the clock would make sense
and especially with the older
quarterback and everything like that
so i mean here we are we're talking
about o-line running back
those type of things i think it is by
far the two big
biggest positional needs you know corner
is another one you can maybe look at on
their football team to go they could use
that as well
but i think the two we've hit on the
offensive side of the ball are
imperative
like if the steelers really want to be
in the conversation for winning the nf
afc north this year gut feeling do the
steelers take a quarterback
this year whoever plays meaningful snaps
for the team and not just injury mason
rudolph snaps i'm talking about he's the
guy
does that happen this year no i don't
think it will i don't
i think i think they're going to be one
i think there's for whatever reason i
feel like there's belief maybe and mason
rudolph could be that guy
i do and then two i don't think they're
gonna be a team that's gonna panic
right right quite yet and just take a
quarterback to take a quarterback
i think they're gonna ride this out with
big ben one more year and see where it
goes
and you know and then try to reevaluate
when he does retire
yeah and i think he will be done after
this year and look they waited 20 years
between terry bradshaw and ben
roethlisberger
hopefully for their sake and for the
sake of steelers fans they won't wait 20
more years to go out and get a
guaranteed franchise quarterback but i
agree with you i think that's something
that they address
next year this year is about loading the
cannon they've convinced themselves
we talked about this when they decided
to keep big ben they had enough time and
space from the end of the 2020 season
to say here's what went wrong here's
what we need to do
we can do it let's go do it let's go all
in
let's try i know that hey this is one of
the teams that when they say they want
to win the super bowl this year they
mean it because they've done what they
had to do to keep the band together
including bringing back juju ms schuster
on a very reasonable one-year deal they
just they have other areas that they've
got to address with guys who can come in
and play right away this is not the year
to waste picks on a quarterback who's
going to be a developmental
type of a player no i don't think so
either that that's right and you know
again mason rule we talked about they
got dwayne haskins to be that
developmental type player right now
right
he's filling that void they're going to
have them let's see let's see what he
looks like
maybe we can groom him into something
there is talent there there's a reason
he was the top 20 pick
so i think that's what they've done with
that little void on their football team
or at least you know
let's just see what we got maybe they
get a diamond in the rough but i think
more than not we're spot on with the
steelers and
uh we've hit the two positions they
really need to to address
and just on haskins yeah when he flamed
out in washington there was this
narrative that oh they really blew it
they screwed it up they never should
take him he still would have been a
first round pick
if washington didn't take him the
steelers got a first round quarterback
from two years ago
for nothing and they get a chance to
evaluate him
and if it works out great if it doesn't
on to the next one yeah it's not like
they gave up a lot to get him
so yeah maybe maybe
for as bad as it was for him in
washington he lands in pittsburgh
he gets groomed he he learns he sees
what roethlisberger does
he straightens out some things he's
still really young you know we expect
these guys right out of college to act
like they're 35 years old
no it takes some time to mature the
brain is still
fully developing it's not fully
developed until you're 25.
they may if this is a minimal risk
potential maximum reward for the
steelers if it works out with dwayne
haskins all right baltimore ravens 27th
overall pick
in the draft they can't leave draft
weekend without what chris
well the baltimore ravens are kind of
like in a really
good spot as a football team all
together
it's it's like it's hard to look at one
spot and just really go
oh man they're desperate right there i
mean to me i think the one that just
jumps out to me more than any
will be the safety position i think
that's probably where i look at
like the baltimore ravens and go wait
with those corners
okay offensive line it's pretty good in
that position
you know defensive line you know edge
guy is certainly another guy that's in
that conversation
um but i guess i would say safety as we
sit here right now it's safety or edge
it's one of those two i'm hemming and
hawing as i'm going through this
but i think it's certainly something on
that defensive side of the ball
uh that i look at and yeah okay i'll say
safety more than anything right now
because they can find ways to be
creative with their front and do things
like that
and get after the quarterback that way
too big shoes to fill
top 10 safety earl thomas no longer with
the team not there anymore
but yeah uh they they got they got to
get past russia
matthew judon gone yannick and gawkway
they give up a third round pick
for you know you you've got two teams
two teams that pissed away pardon me
london significant draft picks for
for yannick and gawkway last year
vikings gave up a second rounder
and then flipped him in the bad way for
a third rounder
from the ravens when they realized we're
not really contending even though they
ultimately did sort of contend and the
ravens gave up a third rounder
for yannick and gawkway who signed as a
free agent with the las vegas raiders so
they better do something there they had
two pass rushers walk out the door in
free agency chris
no i mean mike um it's really the number
one positional need where i i'm
because i just don't know if there's
going to be that legit edge pass rusher
there
like we talked about you know at the end
of the first round
so that's probably their biggest need on
their football
team and that's where i'll stand
corrected i just don't know if they can
get one in the first round that way
to be that guy you know there's there's
the kid olujari who's a really good
like 3-4 outside linebacker type of guy
from from georgia who's a really good
football player mike
but i don't know if he's necessarily
like a big time pass rusher right
i think he's like a really good outside
linebacker edge type guy almost stand up
linebacker
so that's where i guess i got a little
bit of a conundrum there as far as just
like what's going to be available for
them to
address top tier pass rusher type guy
good player is going to be there
available certainly for edge pass
rushers
not sure superstars will be there that
way either so
you know interesting but i look at them
and go i don't know offensively mike i
don't think there's anything we look at
that they need
you know wide receiver okay maybe add to
the group a little bit
but nothing like where you're just like
oh wow they gotta do it
it is it does seem just defense and kind
of adding a little icing to the cake
that way and to me the two positions are
edge and safety like we've been talking
about as to edge rusher judon was the
146th overall pick out of grand valley
state round five in 2016. now it takes
time to develop
if you're looking for impact plug and
play right away the later you draft a
guy the less likely he's going to prove
himself to be ready to go but that's not
a hard and fast rule
the problem with receiver chris when you
cannot attract
free agent receivers when juju smith
schuster takes less
to go play and stay with the steelers
when other free agent receivers kind of
turn up their nose at the idea of
playing in an
offense that doesn't throw the ball as
much and you haven't proven yet that
you're willing to commit to that and you
get sammy watkins who frankly didn't
have a whole lot of other viable options
i think to the extent that you can add
receivers in the draft
and they've got no choice unless they're
going to sit out all year and re-enter
the draft
they have to go to baltimore but i think
that's going to be their primary
mechanism
for getting talent at the position until
they can make
that offense more attractive to free
agents period
because at some point you're going to
have your rookies
cycle off the roster when hollywood
brown you think he's going to take an
extension with the ravens you think he's
going to push his way to free agency
and go get paid somewhere else where
he's going to get used more i so
you i think as long as lamar jackson's
the quarterback
and greg roman is the offensive
coordinator and doesn't open things up
from a passing standpoint
they need to draft receivers because
that's the only place they're going to
get good ones
yeah most likely and again not that it's
last year's draft but there should be
there's plenty of good receivers in this
draft
to where it's not something they'll have
to be desperate to do
you know at the end of first round but
but again maybe somebody's there that
they value you know in a way that's
that's special you know again i don't
know you think about
you know wide receivers that could be
available maybe around then
you know there's the kedarius tony the
university of florida he's a weapon he's
like a
a speed reverse you know you can
go routes big play type of guy he could
be that kind of guy that would fit that
offense a little bit mike but
uh i think the the the necessities we
talked about
are greater for this football team which
is on that defensive side of the ball
and then yeah second or third round
maybe receiver but i think your your
point's real
there's no doubt they certainly look
like a team that's gonna have to
replenish through the draft
you know every few years at the wide
receiver position at least in the lamar
jackson era
the cincinnati bengals have a new ring
of honor they've never had one before
anthony munoz left tackle is one of the
charter members here he is from last
week regarding
his preference for what the bengals do
with the fifth overall pick in the draft
anthony you're going to get you know a
say in who goes next to the ring of
honor
you're going to get some significant
votes but by chance you were given
the power to make a top five pick for
the bengals would you go with an
offensive lineman from the pac-12
or would you go with an offensive weapon
just curious well
let's say first of all i got let's say i
got unlimited of seven guys that i could
vote for the this next year for the ring
of honor i think i'd go
lapa montoya rhymers kazurski walter
moonpi no okay you can't go on linemen
but uh
if they said anthony we're gonna allow
you to make this first pick the number
five pick
i would be pretty excited even though
he's a nemesis he's been a nemesis to my
trojans
i would have to go with the guy up from
eugene oregon with uh penae
i i've watched him several times i think
having signed riley reef you got jonah
you got
hopkins coming back you got sifu i mean
and now you add pine to the mix
i think uh i think if my name was joe
burrow i'd be pretty happy
you know the bengals essentially have
for their purposes
if it goes quarterback quarterback
quarterback quarterback and we don't
know about the fourth pick yet
they could have as a practical matter of
the first overall pick
because they're not yeah in a
quarterback i know anyway here
so so uh you know whether they go left
tackle with penne sewell
whether they go weapon with jamar chase
or a guy like kyle pitts the tight end
that you can move all over the place
i this is a tough call for the bengals
but it's not a tough call that
at some point in this draft you've got
to get offensive lineman to help keep
joe burrow
mobile upright and on the field no
that's right and like
i think the big question is is do you do
that at pick number five
do you want to do that and go offensive
lineman there to me the question with
the bengals at least
you know that's worth talking about here
and anything like that is hey
we know they got jonah williams right he
he they drafted him in the
in the top 10 a few years ago out of
alabama he's going to be their left
tackle
they did get riley reef in free agency
you know an another tackle who's who's
solid
you know middle of the road so like to
me mike i'm trying to figure out with
them
are they going to go wait these are our
two tackles and now we'll wait to the
second round to maybe get a guard or
something like that
and then they do like what you're
talking about
now go jamar chase or kyle pitts or
devante smith one of those three guys i
mean to me that's the interesting thing
about the bengals and their situation at
five like where do you lean when i
kind of bring up those scenarios well i
i i want to protect the quarterback yeah
that's that's the most important and
it's not
it's not as sexy on draft night
and the fans tend to gravitate toward
the
the yeah that's right they're gonna want
to buy the jersey and they're gonna want
on their fantasy football teams and
those are the more exciting players but
uh
it's hard to get too excited about a
football team that can't keep its
quarterback healthy so
i think if you get a great left tackle a
guy who's generational a guy who's going
to be entering potentially the ring of
honor
20 25 years from now that's what you
need to do if you're the cincinnati
bengals plus
the possibility of trading down and
addressing
other needs as well with extra lottery
tickets that's something they can't just
write off
chris that has to be part of your
analysis because they have a lot of
needs
this isn't just a a tweak here or a
tweak there they got the number five
overall pick for a reason now one of the
reasons is joe burrow got injured but
it's not like they were great before
burrow
no was lost for the year they got a lot
of areas where they need to improve yeah
a lot of areas but i i think like my my
logic aligns with yours more or less
when it comes down to it first off i
think sewell is a pretty special
prospect i really do you know again at
six five and change or six six and
whatever he is 326 pounds
he's got special movement ability
you know and maybe for the sake of this
year you put him at guard i don't you
could put him at guard
he could do that riley rifa tackle jonah
williams a tackle and then sewell ends
up going to tackle the next year or
something like that
but but i think uh i'm with you too in
the fact that
you know again if you want to add a
receiver or even another tight end
there's going to be some available there
at the top of the second
but you're not guaranteed of a really
top-end tackle being there at the top of
the second and that to me i think is
where i go like with your logic there
where i'd probably lean
uh offensive lineman tackle for sure
penny sewell
out of oregon if i'm the cincinnati
bengals it would be unfortunate yeah
if the bengals just write off a receiver
at five because
john ross was such a disaster for them
four years ago
i i hope they don't do that i mean i
hope they just make their evaluation
from the standpoint of
what what what what do we really need
here and they
they would benefit from having a game
breaking receiver
uh but they also would benefit from
having
you know somebody to give joe burrow
enough time to get the football to a
game-breaking receiver yeah but
there's a lot look when you get that
franchise quarterback which they have
that's great that's the hard part but
the work is far from over
because then the obligation is to put
the team around him especially chris
when you're in that window before you
have to pay the quarterback
yeah no i mean agreed yeah it's it's
there there's a the receiver's deep they
can get one in the second or third round
if they need it
you know franchise left tackles they're
not gonna be there at the top of the
second round as i find it
highly unlikely that way and you know
your point about joe burrow of course is
real yeah you got to protect him he's
the franchise he's the guy
so let's protect him and then added to
that too you know
they got a guy in joe mixon who i look
at as one of the top running backs in
football as well it'd be nice if they
could open up a hole from him every now
and then to where he doesn't have to
you know always do everything by himself
in the run game
uh that's where i think it makes sense
and then you know the last aspect of
that or last piece of the puzzle i think
that makes sense
you know to why they take offense
alignment is the division they're in
you know they're in a division with a
lot of big bad mean dudes on the
defensive line
you know the steelers the ravens and
then of course the browns that's there's
no slouches
so if you want to beat those teams you
got to be able to block those football
teams too and i think that's where it
makes sense for them to be going to
o-line and tackle with that that fifth
pick
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports